Daniel I understand that you are a huge
david fincher fan that's correct okay so
we have a quote here from David Fincher
to start our interview and if this is
from brainy quote so hopefully it's
correct it says this some people go to
the movies to be reminded that
everything is okay
I don't make those kind of movies any
thoughts on this quote as it relates to
your work I would agree with that but I
think that comes from that goes much
further back than that that good drama
to me is about conflict so it has to be
about stakes so it very quickly tends to
be about life and death kind of a thing
you know the feel-good movies up
probably dealing with that a little bit
less and they find other things that
they're giving the audience humor and
kind of let wholesomeness feeling I like
the stakes thing a lot and I think what
Fincher does really well what very few
people do is that you don't know whether
it's going to end well or badly like he
has made movies that have done either so
if I go and see a Fincher movie today I
genuinely don't know if the protagonist
is going to be okay at the end of the
movie and that is something that I would
love to have in my own movies office
because there is the ultimate suspense
to do that to an audience
where's I think with most filmmakers 99%
of filmmakers you probably know that the
protagonist is going to be okay in the
end and then the other person you know
that it's going to be a dark ending a
horror ending or kind of you know and
Fincher has that great balance so that
is definitely something to aspire to I
think well they say that most of these
blockbuster films are made for the
Middle States and they're made by people
on either coast and I'm butchering that
quote but do you think that most people
who aren't in the arts the people that
maybe just want a neat ending always
feel that way I know I'd ask someone who
said they had a condo in Park City and I
said oh great you get to go to Sundance
you don't have to work heels I hate
those movies oh I said you too how could
you hate those I want to have a nice
clear ending I want to be happy I want
to be a
in the end okay I don't feel that way
but I think with me it depends on the
day
there are days were very much feel that
way and I'm looking at a synopsis for a
movie and it sounds intelligent and
thought-provoking and I'd rather go to
the dentist I watched that movie on that
day because it's just you know too deep
and will involve me too much and some
some days I want that kind of feel-good
movie and then there are other days my
favorite movie this year is the lobster
if you've seen the last incredible and
it's one of those movies where from
moment to moment you have no idea what's
going to be next but every single one of
them is uncomfortable and but you are so
engaged in what's going on because it's
a story that you have never lived
through before worse 99% of other
stories you've lived through before with
different actors with slightly different
storylines but you kind of are in
familiar waters I think if the movie can
put you in unfamiliar waters that in
itself is such an achievement that it
doesn't matter whether it's a good
ending or a bad ending or whatever the
experience that you're being given for
your ten dollars I think is it's
important is it because in this sounds
so trite but it it's about it reminds us
of life but it's not our life we're
watching someone else go through the
fact that most human lives that's our
day we're never sure for a moment moment
is this going to turn out well is the
car in front of us going to cut us off
is this person actually not a friend you
know yeah but that's life but then we
get to watch someone else go through it
and we get to take something away from
it I think what we really want to do is
that we see ourselves reflected in that
struggle so now and leave the theater
with some insight that we didn't have
before and I don't know if it's
necessarily important that that
protagonist who was the vehicle for us
to have that insight it's a happy life
after the movie or doesn't lead a happy
life after the movie as long as I feel
it was a rich experience that makes me a
slightly different person walking out
than I was walking in but it's
interesting that you're saying that
about life because I always have that
argument with genres because life isn't
one genre right
life is funny and life is scary and life
is sexy and life is bomb among all those
things and yet movies for some reason
and marketing presses us into this one
genre we have to decide the worst thing
that can happen to us when we develop
stuff is that we are in between genres
that it's unclear whether it's a
thriller or a drama like every marketing
person will immediately tell you that
they're just poison and you have to go
I thought clearly the one way or the
other way and even if you don't and you
deliver a movie that is in between
genres they will make sure to make it
look like a specific genre they will
decide in marketing the marketing
department will say this is a thriller
and we'll just take the moments that
look like a thriller and put them
together and I think that's when you get
an unhappy audience because they were
coming in with one mindset and then they
were diverted something else but I
always loved movies that stay within
their genre deliver that promise but
also give you sparkles of that real life
that actually jumps genres or reminds me
of David Foster Wallace he wrote the
book Infinite Jest I did an interview
and he said he wrote an article on going
on a cruise which he said was the most
excruciatingly painful experience for
him because they quote forced you to
have fun right and then they would check
in are we having fun and we're gonna do
all these fun things on this itinerary
for the day does it almost feel like
that with certain films where they're
forcing you I think that is scary about
the comedy when they always say that
comedies are harder to make than
anything else which I believe because
all about timing and of a precision know
that making if you look easy and
effortless but the other thing is that
the audience knows at every moment what
you're going for they know in every
moment you're trying to make them love
and have them have a good time which in
a drama or in a thriller I don't have to
be I don't have to lay my cards on the
table that much and say and now I'm
going to try to make you laugh let's see
if this works and every failure it's
blowing up right in your face yeah
that's not the case maybe with a
thriller a little bit because they know
you're trying to create suspense but
it's more over all over the entire
narrative
moment of effort rather than a
moment-by-moment effort worse than a
comedy you know when a joke doesn't land
you know and it's painful and I'm gonna
have that I'm not making comedies and
that I have to subject myself to that
kind of inspection how it reminds me of
the have a nice day t-shirt so for a
while that was really big and like maybe
late 70s 80s and then there was backlash
don't tell me what kind of data right
exactly and that's what you want from
your movies or at least you want movies
I think that's the whole manipulation
discussion I do think that storytelling
is inherently manipulative of course you
want the audience to have a certain
experience that you're trying as a
storyteller to get as much of a grip on
the audience to steer them through the
experience that you want them to have
but if they realize that you're doing
that I think there's a resistance to it
and they are gonna put on the t-shirt
don't tell me what kind of data don't
tell me how to feel you know and the
worst thing that can happen
I forget what I just saw that did that
is where the protagonist is always half
a step ahead of the audience emotionally
like that person is already crying
because something sad is happening but
as an audience I haven't caught up yet
so I don't get to actually experience
the sadness I only get to experience
that protagonists reaction to the
sadness and I immediately see my wall
going up and go like how the movie wants
me to feel sad screw you you know I'm
not gonna feel sad and I think that's
another timing thing that goes for every
genre that you have to time the
experiences and the reactions of the
people in the story to what you think
will be the rhythm of the audience which
is really hard to predict I think and
that's by editing when people always say
the films made and editing I think
that's definitely true for the rhythm of
it all because you have to anticipate
when the audience will arrive at what
point and when you can shoot the next
particle of information or emotion at
them if you get that wrong and it's like
a dance rhythm that is slightly off you
know and I think that's the difference
between a good editor and a bad editor
and then you do test screenings and then
you learn that it's the audience dance
is two completely different
you thought they were and then you recut
the whole thing until you are kind of in
step with your audience
you